a basketball coach has 20 players
available out of them he needs to choose
five for the starting lineup and seven
who will be sitting on the bench in how
many ways can the coach choose these
five plus seven players it is certainly
a huge number but what exactly is it in
this lecture we will learn how to answer
questions of this kind more abstractly
we will develop methods for counting the
number of elements of a given set which
is described in some implicit way now
why do we care the reason is that in
many models the calculation of
probabilities reduces to counting
counting the number of elements of
various sets suppose that we have a
probability model in which the sample
space Omega is finite and consists of n
equally likely elements so each element
has probability 1 over n suppose now
that we're interested in the probability
of a certain set a which has K elements
since each one of the elements of A has
probability 1 over N and since a has K
distinct elements then by the additivity
axiom the probability of a is equal to K
times 1 over n therefore to find the
probability of a all we have to do is to
count the number of elements of Omega
and the number of elements of a and so
determine the numbers K and n of course
if a set is described explicitly through
a list of its elements then counting is
trivial but when a set is given through
some abstract description as in our
basketball team example counting can be
a challenge in this lecture we will
start with a powerful tool the basic
counting principle which allows us to
break a counting problem into a sequence
of simpler counting problems we will
then count permutations subsets
combinations and partitions we will see
shortly what all of these terms mean
in the process we will solve a number of
example problems and we will also derive
the formula for the binomial
probabilities the probabilities that
describe the number of heads in a
sequence of independent coin tosses so
let us get started